I'm gonna make you both happy
I'm waiting with one word PS2 demo discs
I never had a PS2 he he's a Nintendo I'm
a Nintendo boy bro he like
I never had a ps2.
PlayStation console was a PSP I just
realized because I don't know why the
Flat Earth made me think about it and
Rugrats but I I played by Joe goes home
and like worship is [__] Kirby Shrine
and it's like Pikachu your parents
should buy you games huh does your
parents buy you games when I was little
[__] they they would be like Christmas
is coming up you get one game yeah no I
was like that as well but I [__]
cherished that one yeah here's the thing
I'm the [__] idiot who'd buy [__]
straight to DVD games yeah I did I
didn't do that I'm a dumb little kid
right straight to DVD so straight uh
straight to like you know the [__]
back in the day when a movie came out it
had to have a game come out with it oh I
played the Madagascar Xbox game though
that was dog [__] they're all dog [__]
for like one or two that ago The
Incredibles game was hype but I don't
know oh yeah the couple's game is good
but I remember like I had so many demo
discs that came with magazines I think I
played the demo dish more than I played
anything else on PS2 see I didn't get a
shot I don't know maybe it was just
Nintendo were too damn cheap well no
maybe just my area or maybe just
Australia in general but I never had
like the the magazines okay it's uh in
the fridge sorry I I interrupt how Dave
but sorry one's more important okay yeah
fair enough I never had those like
gaming magazines growing up I didn't get
them but my friends would give me the
demo dish when they were done where did
they get them from the magazines the way
they get the magazines from they'd buy
them from where the store
see we didn't we didn't have that the
supermarket sold magazine we no we
didn't have those magazines that came
with those demo discs oh okay I I
they're definitely like UK exclusive
yeah because like obviously the
Australia must have had it you probably
had it like yeah you know you'd get like
I remember I played the Ratchet and
Clank demo okay like 20 plus times and I
don't know I never played the game but I
played the robot battling thing on the
third Ratchet and Clank in the demo I
played that like 100 times the fact that
you
I never could my parents never bought it
for me from that was me with the Metal
Gear Solid one demo you tell me this
yeah yeah it's I mean it was such a good
demo I never got the demos man I just
got the game
[Music]
I just want to mind empty just play some
[__] Mario Sluggers with my friends
dude yeah
you bastard which Mario Sluggers which
console the GameCube one this is [__]
okay never tell you about this thing
that happened to me with the second game
what second marriage Lagos are released
yeah the newest one right so they
released it on the Wii
and I I was in my Wii phase where I was
obsessed with pretty much any any
anything Mario I bought it hell yeah
because you just know it's gonna be
goaded hell yeah dude yeah that's some
great Mario games you know in all the
Mario games that I played up till then
that was sport had served me very well
mainly Mario super strikers
which I was so pissed off with my little
brother for because one day I came home
and he'd stabbed a hole in all of the
plastic of the front
just because he was bored I would kill
my brother and I realized that like that
game also when I was like 17 when I was
selling all my games yeah to buy new
games that one we sold for like full
price if it was like normal oh yeah you
[__] up the front and stabbed it all
so it was only worth like half and I was
frustrated because that was a lot of
money I mean you still got half for it
dude that game you at least in Europe it
was so hard to get a copy of it like oh
I guess yeah UK because like everyone
everyone just like that was like such a
sleeper hit anyway yeah that's such a
good game
um what were we talking about uh they're
Sluggers so for one Christmas the
Christmas prayer I remember I told the
story on Draft House I'd gotten Pokemon
Emerald months early because we imported
it yeah like I don't know where got it
and I was like the coolest [__] kid
in school everyone's like how the [__]
does he have Pokemon Emerald three
months early it came out I was like
already made it already beat the uh
because they had like the battle tower
at that point yeah you want to beat him
already got everything done damn and so
I was like well I'll just do it again
with Super Mario Sluggers yeah I'll get
the game early and I'll I'll [__]
behind how did you get emerald early
my mom ordered it from either America or
China oh okay all right because it comes
out afterwards because this is back in
the day where
um it was Japan America Europe Australia
yeah yeah and they really like Europe
normally
weirdly in some consoles they got
shafted and other consoles they got at
first it was so bizarre how I would end
up working yeah uh normally you could
count in Japan getting it first yes of
course so I might have got a Japanese
copy anyway the Wii had region block so
I got this disc didn't work on the way
obviously we didn't know how to region
blocks we would my parents don't know I
don't know I'm a dumb kid yeah yeah
um and so we my mom had sent it back
this is my Christmas present the one I
was so so excited for and I went through
like a year of trying to get this game
back and forth and I just could not get
it and I think it just didn't release in
Europe in the end I think oh really it's
the baseball game the second one oh the
second one uh I don't know I never
played the second one I only played the
GameCube one my Sluggers so many hours
into that game holy [__] I still have
that I I still have a [__] physical
copy of GameCube Mario sloggers right
that [__] in a party setting bro that
[__] goes hard that should go so hard
you don't even have to know anything
about baseball that game is so fun I've
never played Mario as well because that
was past my Nintendo phase oh dude it's
so good like mine is my Nintendo phase
died with like the GameCube uh that was
like the last console that I owned until
the switch yeah you never play Mario
Galaxy yeah [__] oh
yeah Mario Super Sluggers the game that
I was trying to get my goddamn [__]
hands on for ages yeah never released in
Europe or Australia really we were both
cocked wait what the [__] because I
still called the sequel oh the sequel
okay it was never released in Europe or
Australia and I was trying for like two
years to get it uh just because I
thought it looked really cool yeah it
turns out the game was kind of mad
um but I was still like trying my
goddamn hardest to get it
um and yeah I was really sad about that
I still wake up a cold sweat sometimes
thing I never got to play it you better
player yeah you're playing on stream
because I played like the I played
RollerCoaster Tycoon a [__] town as a
kid yeah same that was [__] that was
so coded yeah that game had no right to
be as good as it was but it was and it
was so fleshed out it was it was so
ahead of its time yeah and then I played
another version of a game it was very
similar on PS1 called just theme park
World okay the logo is ass yeah I played
it on stream one time because I was
super nostalgic about it but holy [__]
is it hard to run PS1 games on an
emulator and find the copy that works
yeah I thought it was fun A lot of fun
yeah all right you can't game for five
years what's the last game that you play
before you I can't play game for five
years just just
like how long do I have yeah how long do
I have how long do you have with the
tickets it's 24 hours so you have 24
hours it's your last day you can't even
beat a [__] RPG it's your last day
it's your last day before you can do
everything else you just can't play
games
oh that's that means purple which is
this theme color yeah it's like uh
I know
uh [__] Pokemon Heart Gold
Pokemon Heart Gold you could beat then
24 hours and that is okay if you say TFT
I'm gonna I'm gonna [__] slap you
dude your Legends I'll kill you do I
have am I like are those 24 hours am I
fully alert like normal or is it like a
normal sleep schedule like a normal
sleep schedule
by 16 hours I'm cooked yeah so tomorrow
you wake up you have all day to play
this game and it's the last game I have
one day yeah yeah you have a full waking
day I would play hard gold bro for five
years five years yeah
honestly right in my head I play I play
TFT
on my head
I guess so hyped to just squeeze in a
game some days when I have like maybe I
got like three meetings in a day you
wouldn't play Bloons Tower Defense oh
that's so good there as well I made my
own in real life uh I think that moment
when I don't know if anyone like when
you have like three meetings lined up
yeah and you have like you have like 50
or 60 minutes and you're like I squeeze
a game in and you do and it's like ah
that was fun because I never get time to
play it so whenever I get a chance to
squeeze one in I'm like yes that sounds
like every time we talk about balloon
style defense on this [__] podcast it
just makes me want to go home and just
play have you have you played it
recently no it is fun really it is I bet
I enjoyed that I watched a four how long
was this video I watched like a three
hour YouTube video from this guy
explains me and it was so [__] good
the new balloons is golden they update
it so much it's actually a great game